all right so something to remember in
in um he has to pass through
Kad okay so when he comes down here and
stops go back one step he we are in
K okay then he cuts down and he goes
around so any koshinaga you can do from
you can do from the beginning
of okay that's very much like for
example he comes for
k
See until he grabs it's
ski okay so for
example he grabs you probably have kot
from
Kat this is a dumb technique okay
that's better to just treat it as
steep you'll have so
likewise you just have to reconcile this
part
here okay so how do you do that I'm
going to fade and then come up and
inside his
Circle take for an inside his
CC if he cuts it down you got to have to
fade more cuz you're going to
get
resistance so you fade Bo then it comes
back
up fade home
okay let's
try all right the good thing about this
technique is that you're going to have
to learn and our camera can walk
wherever they need to
go you are going to have to learn the be
to not do the beginner mistake where
your hips are parallel to
theirs your hips have to turn all the
way around
okay and if you look
up when he makes contact with that
pressure so that this hip is higher than
the other hip when I roll when he hits
me I can use the adhesion to get him up
when I bring my head
sorry here you grab
okay so I'm looking
up and then as I roll I bring him around
me okay A lot of times beginners will
go
parallel and they'll try to get him on
un parallel to him
or they are just
across and hoping that he gets on as
opposed to to make contact here and as
he rolls is bring your hips around he
rolls onto it okay so as I do this
technique you can see that my hip is up
not
down stay there
okay one and I make contact
there not
here
and then as I
move he just easy pey okay I'll do it
again contact
here then I roll my
hips feel good okay let's try that t so
I think that's the main thing is like
make sure you're perpendicular to the to
the Koshi don't be parallel to the kushy
you were you were parallel to the kushy
in the in the problem that you had um
and then uh wherever you can you can't
always and you don't always need to is
make
contact make an adhesion and then as you
turn your hips that's what brings him up
okay not the fact that he's taller than
you or you're lower than him or there's
momentum going over your hip okay um
um another thing
is I tend to have my feet underneath my
hips I tend to be in
chisen um in training because in
application I'm not going to stay there
and I think for me um those the we do
judo throws but if I'm doing a a iido
throw I don't stay underneath the person
okay so some if you like currently I'm
staying underneath him cuz I'm just
going to lower him I'm working on the
Koshi to Koshi angle okay um which is
what I think you should work on but the
there's a you have to be careful because
a lot of people will go like this with
this big steep stance okay and then they
go here and he's on that corner do you
feel that TR and I can kind of muscle
him around
it's not as clean to me as a technique
cuz you're so wide now as opposed to
you're here then I have to put my Koshi
in the right place but the better part
of this is that as I do the technique I
don't have to stay here so as I roll I'm
going to move out so that he falls more
vertical and there's less chance that he
can pull me into the residual
centrifugal energy and if you're wide
you can't step out but if you're in
shenti home you can and he will fall
more vertically less centrifugally you
can't counter you
okay
um we'll go on so as he comes around to
a Shido anywhere that you can get your
hips in that position you have the throw
now this is a much harder Emi so I'm
going to let go so and he can grab
whatever okay but you can see it's
exactly the same grabing with
this I'm loading those hips he's coming
around boom and it's right there okay
and the same thing you can move under
him as you're doing
this and
because boom this way and you would pass
under
him
this
okay
so it's a kind of vicious fall because
he can't grab me unless I let him grab
me and then when you apply my version
where I'm going under him he's pretty
much Fallen 100% at that point okay so a
safe way to do the technique is going to
turn it into exactly the the first
technique that we did okay so I'll give
you reference points okay so he's going
to come
around all right and I go here and he's
going to let go of the outside hand and
now he grabs there okay and so you would
pass under him this hand will go here
and hit the legs as you do everything
okay so
boom you can hold them
up do that side
again long from here as I take his hand
he just goes follow it let me just go
over the top okay doesn't
matter if you're more comfortable is you
go
earlier to underneath doesn't matter
okay okay try